the whole case was just such
[ __ ] like the guy just to give some
context so i don't seem like a total
[ __ ]
like we made a reaction video to this
guy and he said yo you have to pay me
eight thousand dollars or i'm gonna sue
you and we're like well you know [ __ ]
you
eight thousand uh it's fair use it's
there it's fair use you know what i mean
it's like it it it's legal what i'm
doing it's transformative
and so he sues us for copyright
infringement
um and it was just a a really brutal
vindic he
throughout the whole process he was like
okay um
you need to promote me apologize
publicly
and pay me ten thousand dollars it was
always like this escalating
ridiculous requests to humiliate us and
and like he had done this to other
creators so this is a guy who whenever
he's made fun of because he made really
goofy
silly kind of videos and our video about
him wasn't really that bad to be honest
it was
pretty light-hearted and fun but uh he
was super vindictive and he thought he
could
easily just come and come and stomp on
us and and silence our free speech and
our
fair and our right to legal fair use and
so
ultimately he sued us for copyright
infringement and um
over the course of like two years was
just
the most miserable brutal part
you know two years of my life but but
you know we won we run
we won resoundingly and now the lawsuit
is actually
um is a case file you can go to fair use
dot gov and it's one of the
landmark fair use cases and the only one
by the way
on youtube where a creator has won a
precedent a strong question for fair use
so it was a really important actual
legal case
super cool i remember when i found out
about fair use dude my head exploded i
was like oh my god because i was
just in the midst of putting together a
comedy special
where i was going to use footage to
illustrate the
stand-up comedy act what's the what's
the comedy special it's called gnarly
and where can they get that it's
available at stevo.com
right and i've seen it it's very good
thank you man thank you so much
i thought that i was gonna have to
[ __ ] like license every clip
from like mtv comedy center you know
like and and they're like
i find out no it's fair use dude and so
somebody hooked me up with the clearance
attorney who reviewed it and made an
opinion letter and
with that uh legal support um
you know i was able to get insurance for
it so if we ever get in trouble can we
be like awesome
to the judge can we be like you know i'd
like to refer to the h3h3 versus the
youtube community guidelines case
yeah it's a legal it's a legal question
so if there was a fair use
elite court battle like when when they
were writing up papers
and all the documents with super tedious
long-winded
legal arguments they're always citing
different presidential cases and so now
ours is in that lexicon it's pretty
happy and it's a really important one
that a lot of people will cite for
anyone listening who doesn't know what
is
fair use like what exactly are we
talking about
so fair use is a legal doc doctrine in
the united states specifically
each country has their own version of
fair use that says that
you can use someone else's content that
they
own for criticism commentary
newsworthy uh stuff that that's valuable
to the public discord
so that you know it's a really important
doctrine because it means you don't
need someone's permission to criticize
them or
if there's information like in stevo's
case that has historical
relevance or information that's that
contributes to the public discourse
you don't need to license that
information
or or they can or not even license but
they could just say no you can't use it
so it's a very important legal doctrine
that basically uh
you know helps bolster freedom of speech
and and creativity and art yeah like for
example if i'm going to provide
insight and a new perspective that's
factually correct and informative and
beneficial to the public
about the the intricacies of how mike
tyson
broke my [ __ ] nose so dramatically
badly
damn right you're going to see mike
tyson break my nose
and who wouldn't want to see that at
stevo.com
you see right now yeah i mean the most
important thing about
uh fair use is that it's transformative
so yeah they can't
they they they determine is this
competing with the original
art in its in its native marketplace
so if it's siphoning off like that
that's one of the strongest indicators
and so they go well are you just
are people just watching your video as a
substitute for the original well then
that's not fair use you know you're just
stealing business
people who watch my video making fun of
his video
are not watching it as a substitute for
his video they would never watch his
video because they don't
they don't find it entertaining
in the very nature of my video
can i make a video analyzing you
analyzing somebody else that's all fair
use right
yeah yeah yeah you know like
it depends obviously you know has age 38
we could make a video saying hey in this
case we love ethan but we think that he
might have gone a little bit too hard on
this person so let's look at what he
did let's provide him i would love that
video too
you could theoretically uh make that
video sure yeah
but like you know if it's just you
watching the video silently for
for the entirety of it and then you're
like so
that concludes my video that's not fair
use right that's just uh
uh reproduction and distribution
exactly stevo yeah
dude